how can all of these ideas help with
cancer suppression so let's let's go
back to the beginning and ask what what
what what cancer is so I think um you
know asking why there's cancer is the
wrong question I think the right
question is why is there ever anything
but cancer so so in the normal State you
have a bunch of cells that are all
cooperating towards a large-scale goal
if that process of cooperation breaks
down and you've got a cell that is
isolated from that electrical Network
that lets you remember what the big goal
is you revert back to your unicellular
lifestyle as far as now think about that
border between self and world right
normally when all these cells are
connected by Gap junctures into an
electrical Network they are all one self
right that meaning that um their goals
they have these large tissue level goals
and so on as soon as the cell is
disconnected from that the self is Tiny
right and so at that point and so so
people a lot of people model cancer cell
cells as being more selfish and all that
they're not more selfish they're equally
selfish it's just that their self is
smaller normally the self is huge now
they got tiny little selves now what are
the goals of tiny little selves well
proliferate right and migrate to
wherever life is good and that's
metastasis so that's proliferation and
metastasis so so one thing we found and
people have noticed years ago that when
cells convert to cancer the first thing
they see is they close the gap Junctions
and it's a lot like I think it's a lot
like that experiment with the slime mold
where until you close that Gap Junction
you can't even entertain the idea of
leaving the collective because there is
no you at that point right your mind
melded with this with this whole other
network but as soon as the Gap Junction
is closed now the boundary between you
now now the rest of the body is just
outside environment to you you're just a
you're just a unicellular organism on
the rest of the body's environment so so
we so we studied this process and we
worked out a way to artificially control
troll the bioelectric state of these
cells to physically force them to remain
in that Network and so then then what
that what that means is that I'm nasty
mutations like k-ras and things like
that these are these really tough
oncogenic mutations that cause tumors if
you if you do them and then but but then
but then artificially um uh control of
the bioelectrics you you you greatly
reduce tumor Genesis or or normalized
cells that had already begun to convert
to basically they go back to being
normal cells and so this is another much
like with the planaria this is another
way in which the bioelectric state uh
kind of uh dominates what the what the
genetic state is so if you sequence the
the you know if you sequence the nucleic
acids you'll see the Keras mutation
you'll say well that's going to be a
tumor but there isn't a tumor because
because biologically you've kept the
cells connected and they're just working
on making nice skin and kidneys and
whatever else so so we've started moving
that to um to to human glioblastoma
cells and we're hoping for um you know a
patient in the future interaction with
patients
so is this one of the possible ways in
which we may quote uh cure cancer I
think so yeah I think so I think I think
the actual cure I mean there are other
technology you know immune therapy I
think it's a great um technology
um chemotherapy I don't think is a good
is a good technology I think we got to
get out get off of that so chemotherapy
just kills cells yeah well chemotherapy
uh hopes to kill more of the tumor cells
than of your cells that's it it's a fine
balance the the problem is the cells are
very similar because they are yourselves
and so if you don't have a very tight
way of distinguishing between them then
uh the toll that chemo takes on the rest
of the body is just unbelievable so an
immunotherapy tries to get the immune
system to do some of the work exactly
yeah I think that's potentially a very
good uh very good approach
um if if the immune system can be taught
to recognize uh enough of of the cancer
cells that's a pretty good approach but
I but I think but I think our approach
is in a way more fundamental because if
you can if you can keep the cell harness
towards organ level goals as opposed to
individual cell goals then nobody will
be making a tumor or metastasizing and
so on